virtual worlds they can seem to be just
networked computer games or cooperative
quests involving hundreds or thousands
of participants but virtual worlds are
starting to take the form of online
societies making them ripe for social
scientists doing research the way
scientists are using virtual worlds is
the subject of a news feature in a
special section on social cognition in
the September 7th 2007 issue of science
the first time ever we have a technology
a media that not only shows someone what
they're doing but actually captures all
the specific details about all the
nuances of our movements that it allows
for the first time an unprecedented
approach to the study of virtual worlds
and to the study of social action
interaction and transaction that cuts
across many of the disciplinary barriers
that have been in place in prior
research when you do experiments in
virtual reality they're essentially in
principle infinitely relatable under
under the same conditions each of these
scientists use virtual worlds and the
related technology to conduct their
research recognizing that as with every
new technology there are opportunities
and challenges for example MMOs or
massively multiplayer online games
generate a lot of data but making sense
of all of it takes a lot of computer
power for about 12 months of data that
we have collected from one of these MMOs
l quest which is a request to meet by
sony the amount of data that we got from
them form from three servers was about 4
terabytes of data that may not be a lot
by the standards of some of the hard
sciences but in social science that's a
phenomenal amount of data and in order
to manipulate that data to be able to
make it meaningful data on social action
social interaction and social
transactions you need at least another
six times an amount of space so we're
dealing with 24 terabytes of
manipulation space in order to analyze
this data the reason for such large
amounts of data is because every
movement is captured whether keystrokes
on a keyboard or in some cases movements
of your head and body the difference
with a virtual media is that there's a
cycle of tracking and rendering so in
order for me to show you my avatar I
have to send you all the very small
details about how my avatar moves so you
can then draw it on your computer the
difference between that and a video
conference is that all the specific
details and all the very very
fine-grained specifics of the movement
are represented in a non abstract way so
that you can then know everything that
I'm doing
by combining that knowledge with the
ability to create computer-generated
virtual environments researchers gain
more control over their experiments our
evidence suggests that people tend to
behave in the virtual world similar to
how they will behave in a similar
situation in the real world if you're
doing in my experiments in a virtual
environment of course you control the
lighting you control the degree of sound
and all of those in it essentially
external parameters are under your
control that control enables researchers
to conduct experiments that in the real
world would be unethical such as giving
electric trucks to virtual people a
visual appearance in the behavior and
the sounds of the virtual character
actually has an effect on the behavior
of the subjects Russian it doesn't make
any sense everybody knows there's nobody
there there's nobody getting any shocks
there's nobody complaining nevertheless
people responded as if it was a real
person they delayed giving the shops
because it was unpleasant to do so
especially the responses of the virtual
character were unpleasant after they'd
received the shock they are not anymore
and as with every technology
opportunities exist for people to use it
irresponsibly too yes the potential for
misuse here is tremendous we've run
experiments specifically with political
influence and shown that people are more
likely to vote for politicians who copy
aspects of their identity nevertheless
knowing what is possible with this
technology can prevent its misuse
including learning how to detect when
others are using technology to influence
you of course this technology also
allows you to influence others and
misrepresent yourself a characteristic
that provides yet another research path
for scientists studying virtual worlds
if people are acting in a certain way in
a virtual world then that doesn't become
a bug for this approach it becomes a
feature because we are interested in
seeing how people may
agent deception how people may engage in
a behavior that is a different in a
virtual world and they would do in a
real world exactly because our world is
increasingly emerged between back roads
real and the virtual world read more
about these and other scientists
studying social cognition in humans apes
and avatars in the September 7th issue
of science
you
science is published by triple-a s the
science society